a moth goes into a podiatrist office and
the podiatrists office says what's the
problem and the MA says what's the
problem where I begin Norma Donald is
one of those comedians who functions as
a litmus test for people's sense of
humor if you find norm hilarious for
example I know that your sense of humor
and mine are probably pretty similar
norm splits people and if he does so
more than most I think it's because his
vision of comedy is unflinching
unflinchingly devoted to what he finds
funny which means that he won't ever try
to modify his work to appease an
audience of course this has led to what
I think is the mistaken notion one that
you often see in YouTube comments that
norm just doesn't care what people think
because I go to work for Gregory Lynn of
it honestly doc I don't even know what
I'm doing anymore I don't even know if
Gregory Olinda that she knows he only
knows that he has power over me and that
seems to bring him happiness
I think norm cares deeply about his
audiences he wouldn't spend thousands of
hours honing his material if he didn't
want to make people laugh
he just doesn't let the audience dictate
the direction of his work he doesn't
pander in fact during his time at SNL as
the host of Weekend Update he often did
the exact opposite norms distaste for
performing in front of an audience that
was essentially forced to laugh urged
him to tell jokes that would shock them
into silence or gasps a decade before
Ricky Gervais made a splash by making
fun of celebrities at the Golden Globes
norm hosted the SBS with jokes like this
he became the first defensive player to
win the Heisman Trophy congratulations
Charles that is something that no one
can ever take away from you unless you
kill your wife and a waiter
not only does that take bravery it takes
dedication at night I I sometimes wake
up and I turn to some old lady in my bed
that's on my arm a lady that I once
loved doc I don't know where it turned
to my youngest Alexandria she fell in
that in the cold of last year Norm's
dedication to the craft is almost
inhuman and so much of it is unseen he's
one of the smartest well-read people and
stand up particularly well read in
Russian literature if you couldn't tell
by the names that he's making up in the
moth joke and yet his whole act is
predicated on this folksy dopey
innocence he's like that magician from
The Prestige who devotes his whole life
to a character just to pull off a great
trick this is the tree this is a cocoons
I am this is why no one can detect this
medicine total devotion to his own not
so sacrifice this is the hardest pill to
swallow duck laughter boy Gregg raro
they've been a little [ __ ] I no longer
love him Norm's not trying to pull off
tricks of course he's trying to pull off
jokes a joke with a premise and a
punchline it's kind of funny norm was
known for his super short jokes during
his Weekend Update period and now he's
known for these super long rambling
jokes that he often tells on Late Show
appearances it's these longer jokes
which bear a resemblance to shaggy dog
stories that often get him labeled as an
anti comic or a meta comic but he
strongly insists that he is neither of
these things in interviews norm rejects
anything that sees itself as above
comedy looking down on it either to
ridicule or to comment his jokes always
have punchlines and punchlines
that make sense whether or not you think
they're funny he can deliver a joke
quickly hey you know the funniest part
of doing an office conga line when you
look back and realize you're doing it
alone and you're not in an office you're
going to psychiatric Oz but where he can
string out punchlines like pearls on a
wire across a long story this joke from
his special me doing stand-up is 12
minutes long seems like there's too much
news like you know coz now to have
24-hour news now when I was a young boy
the news was half a hour that was the
whole new he starts by talking about
24-hour news and eventually makes his
way to a detailed description of how he
would murder someone and the progression
is completely natural take her body to
the woods and barrier in a very very
very deep grave
along the way there was plenty of
punchlines to laugh at and as things get
crazier you get drawn into a kind of
hysterical ad has vanished chatter fat
I'm kind of happy it's Janice and not
somebody I know I would like to meet her
one day that would be a lot of [ __ ] I
forgot she vanished
every time they will find you in a
shallow grave serial killers are
supposed to be so shrewd and cunning and
yeah but then when it comes time for the
grave
hallo hasty yeah what I would do is I
would like I would look at the lay I
would select a lady and then I would
follow her habits in a sannan-san what
would I be holding in my right hand in
the parking lot but it's cheese sandwich
I got a whole [ __ ] van full of them I
bet get her in there and I would do that
thing that makes me feel like God and
I would take her body to the woods and
bury her in a very very very deep grave
the intelligence of this joke is there
if you want to look for it the word
choices the phrasing it's all precisely
chosen but norm doesn't call attention
to his own intelligence the punchlines
just appear like flashes of light
perhaps I could bring myself to reach
over to that cocked and loaded gun that
lays on the bedside in the constellation
of comedy crates norm is among the least
famous but he's also one of the most
underrated
that's because stand-up was never a
stepping stone for him to greater
success or greater fame but an end in
itself an art to perfect his kind of
comedy is built to last like a low
frequency noise that might not demand
the same kind of attention as high
pitched sounds but will travel a much
greater distance in the end the norms
jokes are the ones you'll remember late
into your life the ones we'll all be
telling for years to come because their
construction is sophisticated but their
delivery is easy to understand getting
that balance exactly right is the work
of an entire career but nor McDonald
more than anyone else knows that a long
winding journey is okay as long as the
payoff is worth it this is duck
sometimes I feel like a spider even
though I have a moth just barely hanging
on to my web with an everlasting fire
underneath me I'm not feeling good
and so the mosque the doctor says
Mothman you're troubled but you should
be seeing a psychiatrist why on earth
did you come here and then the MA said
because the light was on
[Applause]
hey everybody thank you so much for
watching my episode on norm I really
love this comedy make sure you subscribe
to this channel if you want to see more
videos like this every week or so and
subscribe to norms youtube channel at
Norm Macdonald you can find it if you
just type that in where you post his
podcasts and live show this episode was
brought to you by Squarespace if you
want to make a website and you want it
to be a really easy process Squarespace
has some beautiful award-winning
designer templates to choose from that
makes the process so easy and simple
it's got 24-hour customer service no
upgrades nothing to install no patches
ever and picking your domain name is
super super easy you can start your free
trial at squarespace.com and if you use
the offer code nerdwriter you can get
10% off your first purchase